[موسيقى]
تستمر مشاهدينا الكرام بهذه التغطيه من
العربيه للزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا والشمال
السوري اخر حصيله لاعداد الضحايا بلغت الف
وستمائه واحد وخمسين
قتيلا او
11,651 قتيلا
و119 اصابه في تركيا
[موسيقى]
اذا 650
للتصحيح في تركيا والف
ومائه 101
وخمسين عدد الاصابات اذا بحسب اداره
الكوارث هو الطوارئ التركيه فيما سجل
تدمير
1824 مبنى هذا وتشهد المستشفيات في تركيا
ضغوط كبيره بسبب كثره اعداد المصابين اما
في سوريا فقد ارتفعت الحصيله الى 1600
قتيلا بحسب المرصد السوري فيما دمر
الزلزال مئات المنازل في وقت توقعت فيه
الامم المتحده مزيدا من الضحايا في سوريا
جراء الزلزال لا تزال المساعدات بعيده عن
المنكوبين اكان في مناطق النظام السوري او
المعارضه في سوريا
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره
للزلزال الذي ضرب كل من تركيا والشمال
السوري
مساء امس وفجر اليوم طبعا واسفر عن دمار
هائل في البلدين في مناطق عده في الجنوب
التركي وفي الشمال السوري طبعا ايضا عدد
كبير من الضحايا ومن الاصابات ومن
المفقودين الذين ما زالوا تحت الركام حتى
الساعه على صعيد متصل وصل وزير الدفاع
التركي خالوصي اكار الى ولايه هاتاي برفقه
رئيس هيئه الاركان يشار جولر وقائد القوات
البريه موسى اوزيفر كما بدات 17 طائرات
شحن تابعه لقوات المسلحه التركيه لتسيير
رحلات جويه متواصله محمله بالمساعدات الى
ولايه
غازي عنتاب واضنه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وفي سوريا ايضا ومن تحت الانقاض سماع نداء
استغاثه في مدينه بعفرين في محافظه حلب
التي تضررت اضرار كبيره جراء الزلزال
فلنتابع
يلا يلا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من القامش لجمعه عكاش
مراسل العربيه جمعه كيف هي الصوره من هناك
يعني كيف تتم عمليات اغاثه المنكوبين
والمناطق والمباني المنكوبه
يعني دعيني ابدا من حيث انتهيت في مدينه
جنديرس الكرديه التابعه لعفرين وصلت مقاطع
فيديو مؤثره للغايه طفل يلد تحت الانقراض
يعني ولاده الطفل من تحت الانقاض في احد
المنازل المدمره في مدينه جنديرس هكذا
يبدو المشهد في اغلب المدن السوريه التي
يتضررت بفعل الزلزال هذا الزلزال
وارتداداته وما نتج عن رفع اداه الضحايا
في عموم المناطق السوريه الان الى 1200
شخص يتوزعون على مناطق النظام ومناطق
المعارضه حوالي 570 منهم في مناطق النظام
والعدد التقريبي نفسه في مناطق المعارضه
لا يزال الحصيله والاعداد بمناطق النظام
هي اعداد وحصيله رسميه بمناطق المعارضه من
يعني يصدر الحصيله وهل تم رصد جميع
المناطق التي تعرضت يعني لهذا الزلزال
الذي الغير مسبوق في الاونه الاخيره
نعم يعني وزاره الصحافه مناطق النظام
اصدرت الحصيله منذ حوالي الحصيله النهائيه
منذ حوالي 20 دقيقه هي 570 بينما في مناطق
المعارضه نحن نحصل عليها من الدفاع المدني
ومن مشفى ادلب الرئيسي وايضا من مشفى
مشفى عفرين العسكري ارسلته الى الحدث هو
العربيه مقطع
ظهر عشرات الجثث في مشفى
مشفى عفرين
العسكري وفق المصادر من المشفى الان هناك
110 جثث في هذا المشفى لوحدهم يعني حوالي
حوالي
83 84 شخص منهم توفوا داخل هذا المشفى بعد
ان وصلوا اليه بحالات خطيره
وحرجه بينما العدد المتبقي يعني وصلك بعد
ان فارقوا الحياه من انه بسبب النزاع
والحرب في سوريا هناك نقص في
الادوات ويعني المشافي الطبيه هناك كيف
تستطيع المستشفيات اليوم ان تسعف هؤلاء
الجرحى الذين يصلون الى هذه المستشفيات
ماذا عن نقص الادويه الاطقم وغيره
يعني تقريبا كل المشافي وحتى المشافي
الرئيسيه وحتى النقاط الطبيه السريعه
والعيادات الخاصه
امتلات عن بكره ابيها تم استقبال عدد كبير
من الجرحى والمصابين في ممرات هذه المشافي
وحتى على ارصفه هذه المشافي والنقاط
الطبيه بعض الاطباء اضطروا الى اجراء
عمليات جماعيه عمليات جراحيه جماعيه
للمصابين خاصه الذين كانوا يعانون من كسور
في عظام الجسم او كانوا يعانون من حالات
نزيف الداخليه وبالتالي تم اجراء ادخال
مجموعات العنايه المشدده لم يكن في امكان
العديد من المصابين الانتظار يقوم الاطباء
باجراءات عمليات جراحيه خاصه في مشفى
المركزي ومشفى عفرين العسكري شكرا لك جمعه
كاش مراسل العربيه حدثنا من القامش
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
العراق اخلت سلطات اقليم كردستان مباني
سكنيه في مدينه دهوك بشماليه العراق وذلك
بعد مشاعره بهزات ارتداديه في اعقاب
الزلزال المدمر الذي اودى بحياه اكثر من
2000 شخص في كل من تركيا وسوريا كما اعلنت
السلطات العراقيه عدم تسجيل اي وفيات في
البلاد جراء الزلزال حتى الان
سادت حاله من الهلع في العاصمه بيروت
وشمالي لبنان ومختلف المناطق اللبنانيه
جراء زلزال تركيا القوي وشعر سكان لبنان
بهزه ارضيه قويه جدا في الساعات الاولى من
صباح اليوم
ضرب تركيا تبعتها هزه ارتداديه ثانيه اقل
قوه استمرت لثوان وادت الى حاله هلال لدى
الاهالي في مختلف المناطق والنزول الى
شوارع تحت المطر
عندنا ساعه رعب سعه خوف
ما كنت فيني اعبر قد ايه كان في خوف كانت
ليله رعب خوف الايفين انه تقلب البنايه
عليهم وما في مين يطلع فيهم يعني لانه
اكثريتهم فالين اصحاب الاملاك بيجي اخر
الشهر بيقبض بس عنا ما هيدا العامل المعطر
اذا قشطه البنايه امبارح فوق منه بدك
تتفرج تفرج هيدي ما في ترميم بالنبعه قعدت
طلعت هيك العماره في شي عم يبرم بالبيت
عرفنا انه هزه ارضيه اهملتها الاولاد
وطلعت بنص الطريق
كل شي اطفال من عمر 3 سنين وانت طالع نيم
بالطريق امبارح لهلا اذا بتحب تروح تشوف
شوف العالم كلها نايمه من ورا هالليله
امبارح ليله كتير كانت صعبه على العالم
شاهدينا قبل ان انتقل الى مراسلنا في كل
من اربيل وبيروت ساشير الى هذا العاجل
الذي ورد الان عن ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان يعزي الرئيس التركي
في ضحايا الزلزال اذا بالعوده لرصت هذا
الزلزال في كل من اربيل وبيروت ينضم الينا
من اربيل احمد الحمداني مراسل العربيه ومن
بيروت ناهد يوسف مراسلات العربيه سابدا
معك ناهد كيف هي الصوره من هناك خصوصا ان
اهالي بيروت وشمال لبنان تحديدا شعروا
بهذه الهزه في ساعات الصباح الاولى
والعديد منهم اضطر الى النزول الى الشارع
لا تزال حاله الرعب مسيطره على اللبنانيين
عموما بعد هذا الشعور المرعب الذي احسه به
عند حصول هذا الزلزال يمكن القول ليال او
يمكن وصف مشاعره به اللبنانيون بانه يعادل
الرعب الذي شعروا به بان او عقب انفجار
مرفا بيروت بسبب الاهتزاز الكبير الذي
شعروا به في منازلهم وعليه كما ذكرتي
كانوا نزلوا الى الطرقات عدد كبير منهم
ناموا في سياراتهم باتوا ليله هذه الليله
في سياراتهم خوفا من حصول ارتدادات اخرى
لهذا الزلزال صدقت التكبيرات في المساجد
خلال كل ساعات النهار اليوم قبل الاذان
وبعد الاذان كانت التكبيرات تصلح من
المساجد في بيروت
هناك بعض المنازل التي اخليت وهي المنازل
ذات البناء القديم او البناء العشوائي
كانت اخليت من من سكانها خوفا ايضا من اي
تصدعات اجراءات قامت بها او
رئيس الحكومه الى كل من وزير
عفوا الى هيئه الكوارث لجنه الكوارث حيث
اجتمع معها اليوم وطلب منها ان تعاين اي
تصدعات او تشققات في المباني او في
الطرقات ان كانت هناك من تصدعات كي يتم
تفادي اي حصول الاسوا في حال حصلت اي
ارتدادات اخرى وايضا هناك في هذه اللحظات
ليال في مطار رفيق الحرير الدولي وفد
لبناني في طريقه الى اضنه يشارك فيه فوج
الهندسه في الجيش اللبناني بالاضافه الى
وفد من فوج اطفاء بيروت والدفاع المدني
ووزير البيئه وذلك للوقوف على مطالب
الدوله التركيه هم الاتجاه بطريقهم الى
اضنه للمساعده في عمليه رفع الانقاذ وطبعا
على الوقوف على كل الاضرار التي حصلت يعني
بما يمكن للبنان من تقديم مساعده الى هناك
اما في لبنان الان فالصوره على حالها هناك
الخوف وترقب من حصول اي ارتدادات اخرى نهد
ابقي معي لو سمحتي يعني هناك حصيله جديده
لضحايا الزلزال وردت الان في سوريا
1383 قتيلا
وثلاثه وفي تركيا
1651 قطرا اذا اعداد الضحايا تزداد يعني
بعد هذا الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب كل من
تركيا وسوريا الى اربيل احمد الحمداني
احمد كيف هي الصوره من هناك وكيف شعر
اهالي اربيل بهذه الرداد
الهزات الارتداديه والهزه الكبيره التي
ضربت تركيا وسوريا
بالفعل طبعا اربيل ودهوك اكثر مناطق التي
شعرت بالهزات الارضيه والزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا وان في ساعات الصباح الاولى هرع
الناس واخلوا
منازلهم خصوصا المناطق التي في العمارات
السكنيه في دهوك واربيل نزلوا الى الشوارع
واخلاقوا المباني على الفور وبقوا في
الشوارع لعده ساعات حتى انتهت
الهزات الارتداديه طبعا صحيح ان هناك هزات
ارتداديه بعد خمس او ست ساعات طبعا ضربت
تركيا وشارت بها ايضا اربيل ودهوك وان
بالمقابل هناك عده اجراءات قام بالدفاع
المدني من توعيه وارشادات واجراءات اخرى
واستنفار في في وزاره الصحه في اقليم
كردستان ولا يفوتني ان وزاره الصحه في
اقليم كردستان ارسلت مساعدات طبيه
ومساعدات طبيه الى تركيا والى سوريا
وطبعا كان هذا بقرار من رئيس الوزراء
مسروق بارزاني بالتالي فان هناك تعاطف
كبير في كردستان لما يجري في سوريا
وتركيا والتعاطف على مستويات القياده
السياسيه هنا في اقليم كردستان ومستوى
الشعبي ولكن يبقى تبقى مخاوف من عوده
الهزات الارتدا هي هو شعور السائد بين
سكان العمارات السكنيه
هناك بحاله تاهب تحسبا لاي يعني
ردات على هذا الزلزال او اي يعني تبعات
لهذا الزلزال في ساعات المقبله
بالفعل حاله تاهب بين الاجهزه الامنيه
والخدميه على حد سواء في اقليم كردستان
وطبعا من بينها وزاره الصحه وايضا الاجهزه
الامنيه ولديها ما لديها من تعليمات على
لعمل كل الاجراءات الاحترازيه في مساعده
السكان فيما اذا لا قدر الله كان هناك
ضربه او زلزال او هزات ارتداديه في في
اربيل او في السليمانيه او حتى في دهوك
لكن وطبعا لا يفوتون ايضا ان اذكر ان ال
الموصل المتاخمه لدهوك واربيل ايضا شعروا
بهذه الهزات او بهذه الزلزال احمد
الحمداني مراسل العربيه ساعه الاولى من
صباح تحدثنا من اربيل وايضا شكرا لك ناهد
يوسف مراسلات العربيه حدثنا من بيروت
في حلب اظهرت الصور في شارع بلال في حي
صلاح الدين انهيار مبنى بالكامل فلنتابع
وفي مقابلات مع العربيه قال المدير
الاقليمي للجمعيه الصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
حسام شرقاوي ان الوضع الامني في سوريا
يعيق عمليه وصول المساعدات وفرق الانقاذ
الى المناطق المتضرره جره الزلزال
كتير دول قامت والطائرات تتحرك والقافله
تتحرك خاصه من الدول المجاوره
وعلى خلال ساعات الدعم وصل خاصه من الدول
المجاوره
توصيل الدعم داخل سوريا طبعا له في صعوبات
انه نوصل داخل سوريا كون المطار وضعه
ماساوي
ونوصل الدعم للمناطق المنكوبه خاصه انه
العاصفه الثلجيه اللي صار لها كذا يوم
الان مستمره
تعيق
التوصيل الدعم وبرضو الوضع الامني
وفي مقابله مع العربيه اوضح المدير
الاقليمي لجمعيات صليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
حسام الشرقاوي ان مدى استعداديه فرق
الهلال الاحمر وفرق الانقاذ في سوريا كانت
ضعيفه جدا في ظل غياب جهزيه الاليات
والمعدات بعد عشر سنوات حرب في للاسف في
سوريا
والمقاطعه والتوابعها
مدى استعداديه الهلال او فرق الانقاذ
ضعيفه جدا اول طلب كان لاليات اليات رفع
وانقاذ
للناس وهذا غير موجود للاسف هو بنحاول
الان اوكي نوصل بعض قطع الغيار وغيره
وغيره ومهم جدا طبعا نوصل للناس للناس
الموجودين تحت الانقاذ
نكمل البحث
والانقاذ والاسعاف الاولي مهم جدا برضو
نركز على عشرات الالاف الان بلا ماوى مياه
بلا اكل
اعلن البيت الابيض عن ان واشنطن على تواصل
لدعم الحكومه التركيه والمنظمات الانسانيه
في سوريا فيما اوضح وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
تقيم خيارات الاستجابه الشامله للزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا واكد بلنكن
في بيان ان بلاده ستبذل كل ما في وسعها
لمساعده المتضررين خلال الفتره المقبله
مضيفا ان واشنطن على اتصال وثيق مع انقره
وشركائها في المجال الانساني لتحديد ما
تحتاجه المنطقه في الايام القادمه يمكن
اشار الى ان جهود الاستجابه الدوليه في
تركيا جاريه بالفعل مؤكدا ان المنظمات
الانسانيه المدعومه من واشنطن في سوريا
تستجيب لاثار الزلزال في جميع انحاء
البلاد
للحديث عن المساعدات الاوروبيه لكل من
تركيا وسوريا تنضم الينا من برلين راغده
بهنا مراسله العربيه ومن بروكسيل نور
الدين الفريدي مراسل العربيه نور الدين
سابدا معك عندما يعني يعلن الاتحاد
الاوروبي والمسؤولين عن تفعيل اليه الدفاع
المدني في الاتحاد الاوروبي ماذا يعني ذلك
وما هي المساعدات التي ابدى الاتحاد
الاوروبي تقديما لكل من تركيا وسوريا
اذا على ما يبدو فقدنا الاتصال بالزميل
نور الدين ساعود الى راغده
راغده يعني المستشار الالماني اعلن عن
ارسال داعم لكل من تركيا تحديدا ما هي ما
هو هذا الدعم التي ستقدمه المانيا وماذا
عن الدعم لسوريا
مساء الخير ليال بالفعل وزاره الداخليه
الالمانيه هي التي تنسق هذه المساعدات
بشكل مباشر مع تركيا كان هناك اعلان بانها
سترسل خيم وبطانيات اضافه الى
يعني اضافه الى امور اخرى يمكن استخدامها
في حالات الطوارئ ولكن يعني الوضع في
سوريا هذه كلها هذه المساعدات سترسل الى
المناطق التركيه تحديدا منها ايضا
مواليدات كهربائيه للطوارئ ولكن الوضع
اصعب في سوريا لانه حسب مقاله الحكومه
الالمانيه حتى الان التنسيق في المناطق
السوريه يجري مع المنظمات غير الحكوميه
والتي هي اصلا المانيا تنسق معها
المساعدات لهذه المناطق يعني قبل هذه قبل
هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب الحدود التركيه
السوريه
عندما سئل المتحدث باسم الحكومه صباحا ما
اذا كان سيكون هناك التواصل مع النظام
السوري قال حتى الان الوضع يعني غير واضح
وما زلنا نقيمه ولكن حتى الان التنسيق يتم
مع الخطوط التي ننسق معها سابقا وتحديدا
المنظمات الدوليه العامله في هذه المنطقه
لذلك
كنت اقول يعني يمكن يتغير هذا الوضع في
ساعات المقبله بحسب تطور الوضع في الاراضي
السوريه وما اذا رات الحكومه الالمانيه
هنا حاجه للتواصل مع النظام السوري لانه
المتحدث الحكومي ترك هذه النقطه مفتوحه
يعني يمكن ان تتغير في الساعات ابقى معي
راقده ساعود الى نور الدين الفريدي مراسل
العربيه من بروكسيل نور الدين كنا يعني
نسال عن اليه الدفاع المدني في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ماذا تعني كيف وما هي المساعدات
التي قدمت لتركيا وسوريا حتى الساعه
يعني فئه اللحظات وصلت
وصل عدد الفرق فرق الاغاثه التي ارسلتها
الدول الاوروبيه الى 19 فريق اغاثه ارسل
من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي بصفه الجماعيه او
على صعيد ثنائي الى تركيا كيف يتم ذلك
يوجد هنا في بروكسل جهاز يسمى باليه
الحمايه المدنيه هذا الجهاز تابعه للاتحاد
الاوروبي منذ الصباح او منذ فجر اليوم
استقبل طلبات تركيا المتعدده التي تركزت
في مرحله اولى حول فرق الاغاثه وفرق
النجده يعني رجال متخصصين في في مواجهه
مثل هذه الكوارث الطبيعيه والطب العاجل او
العمليات الاستعجليه بما تحتاج من ادوات
سواء كان معدات طبيه ادويه خيام الى غير
ذلك لاقامه المستشفيات المدنيه هناك يعني
العدد الاجمالي
للعاملين في هذه الفرق وبالمئ ربما اكثر
من الف اوروبي من سته عشر بلدا والاعداد
تتغير من لحظه الى اخرى
الطلبيه تركزت في مرحله اولى
باختصار لو سمحت ساعود اليك لنفصل هذا
الموضوع تفضل
اذا الطلبيه تركزت في مرحله الاولى حول
فرق الاغاثه والطب الاستعجالي ولكن
الدائره الاوروبيه المتخصصه هنا تعمل على
مدار الساعه في انتظار الطلبات ستاتيها من
تركيا او ربما من النظام السوري اذا تغير
الموقف والاتحاد الاوروبي اعلن عن
استعداده لتقديم المساعدات الى سوريا اذا
طلبت ذلك في الاثناء فان المساعدات ستصل
السوريين في الداخل السوري المنكوب عن
طريق هيئات الاغاثه وعن طريق مكتب او بعثه
الاتحادي العامله في بيروت ابقوا معي
مراسلين العربيه سانتقل الان الى عمان
وعبر زوم رولا الامين المتحدثه باسم
المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
سيده رولاسا ابدا بالموضوع السوري طبعا
بسبب يعني كل الدول اليوم دول العالم بدات
بارسال فرق انقاذ ادوات مساعدات الى تركيا
ولكن في سوريا حيث تنقسم المناطق المنكوبه
بين مناطق تابعه لسيطره النظام ومناطق
تابعه للمعارضه حتى الساعه الدعم يقتصر
على المنظمات غير الحكوميه الموجوده هناك
كيف يعني ستتعامل الامم المتحده مع هذا
الموضوع وكيف ستتاكد من ايصال كل
المساعدات المطلوبه للمنكوبين هناك
شكرا على اضاءه الاضاءه على هذا الوضع
الشائع جدا والحب محزن جدا جدا كما تفضلتي
الوضع داخل سوريا يعني كان ماساوي قبل
الزلزال والان الزلزال يجعل الوضع كارثي
اكثر من
15.3 مليون سوري كانوا يعتمدون على
المساعدات الانسانيه كانوا يعانون من
الازمه الاقتصاديه القويه من 12 عام من
الازمه السوريه من دمار من
صعوبه في تحصيل اي نوع من العمل والان هذه
الازمه هذا الزلزال اتى ليضرب في كل
محاولاتهم لحمايه عائلتهم يعني عرض الحائط
يجب ان نتذكر انه في سوريا هناك مازال
اكثر من 6.8 مليون سوري نازحون داخل سوريا
ماذا يعني هذا يعني انهم يعيشون اما في
خيم او في مقاول وبيوت ربما
مدمر بعضها بدون شبابيك بدون ابواب هي
بيوت ولكنها ضعيفه وهشه هذا حتى ان لم
يؤدي الى دمار هذه البيوت اصبحت غير مؤهله
لان تكون بيتا على كل حال هذا يفسر كميه
الدمار الهائله التي ضربت المناطق السوريه
يعني حتى اكثر من المناطق التركيه بسبب ان
هذه المباني اصلا متصدعه منذ الحرب ومنذ
ان بدات الازمه السوريه طيب اليوم
المساعدات التي ستصل الى سوريا من اي معبر
ستدخل كيف ستصل الى المناطق هل هي فقط
لمناطق المعارضه ام ستكون ايضا للنظام
يعني ما الذي سيحدث هناك خصوصا ان روسيا
ايران عدد من الدول الداعمه للنظام حتى
اسرائيل اعلنت عن ارسال مساعدات للنظام
اسرائيل لنظام ما بعرف انا بقدر احكيلك عن
ايش الامم المتحده نحن قد ارسلنا مساعدات
الى
المناطق المنكوبه وبعضها يتم توزيعه في
هذه اللحظه هناك المزيد يتم ارساله طبعا
نحن موجودون داخل سوريا في المناطق التي
يسيطر على تسيطر عليها الحكومه ونعمل منذ
سنوات ولدينا اليا للعمل
ولديها على الارض وهم يقومون بغاثه
الاهالي منذ الصباح في شمال سوريا في
مناطق ادلب الوضع معقد اكثر لان هذه
المناطق نحن لسنا موجودين على الغرب نحن
نعمل في غزه عنتاب كبقيه وكالات الامم
المتحده ولنا شركاء على الارض يقومون
بتوزيع المساعدات منطقه غازي عنتاب هي
كانت مركز هذا الزلزال وهي وهي كانت مركز
للوكالات التي ترسل الى الداخل فهذا يعني
اعاقه اضافيه شلل جزئي لعمل هذه الوكالات
شلل بس يؤدي الى صعوبات وتحديات داخل
المناطق المنكوبه ايضا هناك انقطاع في
التيار الكهربائي انقطاع في الطرقات ليس
فقط بسبب الزلزال ولكن بسبب الطقس الشديد
البروده والعواصف الثلجيه التي ادت الى
اغلاق الكثير من الطرقات التي يستعملها
عمال الاغاثه والشركاء على الارض وهذا
يعني ان هناك من يحتاج الى الاغاثه ولم
يصل لا يعني ايضا بما انك تتحدثين عن
الواقع بشمال سوريا هم يعانون اصلا من
ازمه كهرباء حتى قبل هذا الزلزال واليوم
يعني عمليه الاغاثه خصوصا في الليل ستكون
صعبه كيف ستساعدون بهذا الموضوع وماذا عن
المساعدات الطبيه خصوصا ان المشافي هناك
ايضا تعاني من نقص حاد على جميع المستويات
منذ ما قبل هذا الزلزال صحيح يعني هناك
الالاف من الجرحى ونحن نعلم انه داخل
سوريا حتى في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
الحكومه فقط نصف المستشفيات تعمل بشكل
كامل فهناك حاجه كبيره في هذا الوضع ولكن
يجب ان نتذكر ايضا ان هذا الزلزال ضرب
يعني هؤلاء مع معظمهم نازحون والكثير منهم
نازحون ونزحوا اكثر من مره وهم يعانون من
الازمه الاقتصاديه ويعانون لانهم ليسوا
كمبيوتر هذا الزلزال اتى له نتائج كارثيه
يجب ان ناخذ ايضا بعين الاعتبار انهم
الكثير منهم على الان يتوجب عليهم ان
يخلوا البيوت التي كانوا يقيمون فيها حتى
لو لم تدمر لانها ركيكه ولانها ماذا يعني
يعني ان في هذه الليله التي فيها العاصفه
على اقصى ما يكون في شده البروده وفش
الثلج الناس يلتحقون السماء البارده
والثلوج خوفا من ان يكونوا موجودين داخل
اي بيت او خير نظرا كما نقول يعني الزلازل
المتكرره التي حدثت حتى لو كانت بقوه اقل
ولكن هذا يحدث قلق وخوف عند الاهالي من ان
يناموا هذه الليله بيوتين فهم ينامون في
العراء في ظل العواصف الثلجيه والامطار
الشديده والرياح الشديده يجب ان يتم هناك
تضافر جدي وحقيقي وذات معنى من الجميع
لاغاثه بهذا بهذا يعني التكافل التكافل
الدولي الانساني الذي تتحدثين عنه كان
هناك يعني
تصريح للامم المتحده بعد ظهر اليوم عن نقص
بالامدادات وحاجه للدعم الدولي هل يعني
هناك بوادر بهذا الموضوع وكيف ممكن ان
يؤثر هذا الموضوع على ما تقومون به على
الارض لنجدد هؤلاء يعني احنا حتى قبل هذه
الازمه كان هناك نقص في التمويل وحتى
المساعدات الشتويه التي عاده نوزعها على
الملايين من النازحين واللاجئين
اضطررنا الى خفت العدد الان هناك بعض
الدول المانحه تقول انها على استعداد
للدعم ما نقول نحن ليس فقط الدول النامحه
الغربيه هناك حاجه لدور اقليمي من الدول
العربيه المجاوره ايضا
والقادره هناك دور للافراد هناك حول
الشركات لان الاحتياجات كبيره ويجب ان
نتذكر انه بعد 12 عاما من الازمه الحياه
تصبح اصعب على اللاجئ والنازح ولا تصبح
اسهل لانهم يعانون اكثر قدراتهم على حمايه
اطفالهم ارسالهم الى المدرسه توفير الطعام
تقل مع كل عام لذلك يجب ان نقف مع هؤلاء
في هذا الظرف وبالتالي انت تواجهي الرساله
اليوم لكل الدول المانحه الدول القادره
على الوقوف الى جانب هؤلاء على الوقوف الى
جانب الامم المتحده بهذه المحنه وبهذه
الكارثه الانسانيه شكرا لك رولا الامين
المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه الساميه للامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا
وبالحديث ايضا عن المساعدات قال رئيس
برنامج الغذاء العالمي ان فرق الطوارئ
التابعه للبرنامج تستعد لتقديم المساعده
اذا اقتضت الضروره بعد زلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا وقدم عبر حسابه على موقع
تويتر تعازيه لعائلات الضحايا ضحايا
الزلزال الذي بلغت شدته سبعه فاصله سبعه
درجات على مقياس
اذا ساشير مشاهدينا الى هذا العاجل الذي
ورد الان الصحه العالميه تقول بان الارقام
الاوليه عن ضحايا الزلزال بسوريا وتركيا
سترتفع بشكل كبير اذا كان هذا اخر يعني
العواجل حول موضوع الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا خصوصا ان عمليات البحث ما زالت
جاريه هناك المئات لبل الالاف تحت الانقاض
ليس هناك من حصيله رسميه حول الاعداد
المفقوده حتى الساعه ومن هنا اتى تصريح
الصحه العالميه بان الارقام الاوليه عن
ضحايا الزلزال في كل من تركيا وسوريا
ستزداد بشكل كبير في الساعات المقبله
ساعود الى مراسلي العربيه من برلين راغده
بهنام ومن بروكسيل نور الدين الفريضي نور
الدين يعني ساعود اليكم نتحدث عن اليات
المساعده من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي خصوصا
ان الامم المتحده اليوم تواجه ازمه
بطريقه يعني بكميه المساعدات وبايصال
المساعدات ما الذي سيفعله الاتحاد
الاوروبي بهذا ايضا
يعني في هذه المرحله التي اتحاد الاوروبي
تلقى طلبا عاجلا من تركيا
يتركزوا حول حاجتها الماسه والعاجله لفرق
الانقاذ وفرق الطب العاجلي طب الطوارئ تم
ارسال او يتم في غضون الساعات ارسال فرق
تعد المئات من رجال الانقاذ والياتهم
وكذلك الاطباء العدد ربما سيتجاوز الالف
في غزون اليوم في البدايه كان الحديث عن
فريقا ثم سته عشر ثم تسعه عشر وبالتالي لا
نتحدث الان عن عدد نهائي وانما عن عدد
يتزايد ربما من ساعه اخرى لكن تبقى
الحاجيات الملحه الكبيره جدا غير المحدوده
لملايين
الضحايا او على الاقل مئات الاف ضحايا
مكان داخل تركيا في الشمال السوري في
مناطق سيطره المعارضه وفي الداخل السوري
في المناطق
او تحت سيطره النظام السوري فيما تعلقوا
بتركيا طبعا التصور واضح وهناك السلطات
التركيه التي تتواصل راسا مع جهاز الحمايه
المدنيه التابع للاتحاد الاوروبي هنا في
بروكسل هذا الجهاز يقوم بتنسيق طلباتي
تركيا
وما تقدمه الدول الاعضاء
بشكل منفرد سواء كان على طريق الصعيد
الثنائي او بصفه جماعيه هذا الجهاز يقوم
بتنسيقها يراجع مع تركي حاجياته وبالتالي
الفرق تذهب اتباعا وفق الحاجيات التي
تقدمها تركيا
العمليات ككل الجاريه الان الاتحاد
كالاتحاد يغطي خمسه وسبعين في المئه من
نفقاتها الماليه في الانتظار طبعا هناك
حاجيات مئات الالاف من من الضحايا للخيام
لمعدات التدفئه للمستشفيات الميدانيه
للمواد الغذائيه بالنسبه للوضع يبدو دقيقا
بالنسبه للشمال السوري وكذلك للداخل
السوري الاتحاد الاوروبي قال ان سوريا
يعني سوريا اتحدث هنا عن السلطه في دمشق
لم تقدم طلبا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا
امر معروف باعتبرنا ان هناك انظمه عقوبات
شديده مفروضه على النظام ولكن الاتحاد
الاوروبي يبدي استعداد لتقديم المساعدات
مباشره الى سوريا ولكن في الاثناء ما
تقدمه ما يقدمه او الفرق الاوروبيه اما عن
طريق تركيا الى الشمال السوري من خلال
هيئات الاغاثه التي القائمه في الميدان
منذ سنوات او عن طريق او الى داخل السوري
عن طريق هيئات الاغاثه الدوليه والاخرى
التابعه المتحده والتي تعمل بشكل موثق
وثيق وبتعاون وثيق مع
هيئه الاتحاد الاوروبي خاصه بعثه الاتحاد
في بيروت وهي بعثه مكلفه بالعلاقات مع
سوريا وهي ايضا لها تج في التعامل معه
هيئات الاغاثه العامله داخل السوري وهذا
على مدى مره سنوات في هذه المرحله يعادي
ترتيب الاوروبيات على ثم
علاوه على المساعدات العينيه مساعدات
اتحدث عن فرق اغاثه يعني تساعد في عمليه
الانتشار كما حصل في تركيا يعني وصلت فرق
اغاثه عديده من دول اوروبيه من دول في
المنطقه هل هناك اي يعني
بوادر بتسيير فرق اغاثه الى شمال سوريا
يتم ذلك من عبر الحدود السوريه عبر الحدود
السوريه التركيه وبالتنسيق مع السلطات
التركيه في هذه المرحله فرق الاغاثه ستصل
الى الشمال للسوري ولكن بالتنسيق مع
السلطات الفاعله في الميدان وهي من
الناحيه التركيه من الجانب التركي هي
السلطات التركيه والفاعله في الميدان هي
تنظيمات وهيئات الاغاثه واليات القائمه
الاداريه التي شكلتها المعارضه على مدى
السنوات ولكن بالنسبه للداخل السوري
يبدو ان خاصه هي منطقه حلب التي تعرضت
لدمار كثيف منها المراجع التاريخيه وهنا
العمل يتم بين التعاونيه وبين المنظمات
غير الحكوميه والاداره السوريه بمعنى هنا
النظام في دمشق وهذه المنظمات تاتي تعمل
منذ سنوات بترخيص من الاداره في سوريا
وبالتالي لها علاقات ولها خبره في التعامل
في الميداني بينها وبين النظام في في دمشق
يبقى يبدو ان الدمار في الجانب السوري هو
اكثر في المناطق التي تسيطر عليه المعارضه
فدخول المعونات هنا وفرق الاغاثه يتم بشكل
اساسي بالتنسيق مع السلطات التركيه
والتصور وانه بطريقه غير مباشره او مباشره
مع النظام في سوريا ولكن السلطات الفاعله
في الميدان مثل ما يقال في هذه الحالات هي
الجهه التي يتم التعامل معها مباشره تفضلي
نور الدين اسمح لي ان انتقل الى زميله
راغده بهنان مراسلات العربيه من برلين
رغده كنا نتحدث عن المساعدات الالمانيه
الرسميه التي اعلن عنها هي للجانب التركي
بموضوع الدعم لسوريا كنت قد افتن بان هناك
تريث حتى الساعه ولكن الدعم الذي ممكن ان
يقدم هل سيقتصر على المناطق التابعه
للمعارضه هناك
لا بوادر حتى الساعه ومعلومات عن هذا
الموضوع
التنسيق الذي يحصل يعني بين المانيا
والجانب السوري هو يعني كما ذكر نور وهو
اعتقد انه موقف اوروبي موحد يتم عبر
المنظمات الانسانيه الموجوده هناك الحكومه
كانت تقول بانه هي اصلا يعني من ثاني اكبر
مانح لهذه المناطق هناك عبر هذه المنظمات
الانسانيه الموجوده التي تعمل في المناطق
السوريه الواقعه على الحدود مع تركيا وهي
بالتالي لديها منظمات تعمل معها يعني في
السابق قبل ان يقع هذا الزلزال وهي حتى
يعني قبل ساعات كان الوضع بانه هي مستمره
بالعمل
[موسيقى]
500 الف يورو دعم من الحكومه الالمانيه
للصليب الاحمر الالماني لكي يدعم هذه
العمليات الاوليه هناك بالطبع اضافه الى
تنسيق يعني داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني
هذه يعني هذه مساعدات المانيه المانيه فقط
بغض النظر عن دعمها ايضا للجهود الاتحاد
الاوروبي
شكرا
لكم على هذه الرسائل
[موسيقى]
هي هون مكان نروح فيه نحن
شغل رب العالمين هذا هون
[موسيقى]
ليه
خوف
[موسيقى]
من اسطنبول ينضم الينا زيدان زنكلو مراسل
العربيه زيدان كيف هي الصوره من هناك هل
هناك اي هزات ارتداديه في يعني الساعه
الماضيه وكان هناك تصريح للصحه العالميه
تتحدث عن ان العدد مرجح للارتفاع كثيرا
اتحدث عن عدد الضحايا كيف هي الصوره من
تركيا
نعم بدايه اعلنت تركيا قبل حوالي ساعه من
الان الحداد الوطني لمده سبعه ايام
في عموم البلاد حداد على ضحايا الزلزال
عدد الضحايا وصل الى
1651 شخصا هناك اكثر من 11 الف
مصاب واكثر من 5600 مبنى مقدم في عشر
ولايات في جنوب تركيا بالتالي الحصيله
مرشحه للارتفاع هذه حصيله اوليه ما زالت
تعلنها السلطات التركيه تباعا فرق الانقاذ
بدات في الوصول من عده الدول الاولى
الواصلين او اول الوافدين كانت من
اذربيجان فريق الانقاذ او فرق الانقاذ
التي ارسلتها الى تركيا وصلت وفق ما ذكرت
عده مصادر تركيا هناك ايضا
فرق مساعدات من الدول
عديده اسمح لي ان اذكر بان اداره الكوارث
التركيه اصدرت الان بيان يقول بانه تم
تدمير 5,6
مباني حتى الان جراء الزلزال
نتحدث عنها قبل قليل اكثر من 5600 مبنى
دمرت في عشر ولايات تركيه هي اخر احصائيه
طبعا كما كنا نتحدث قبل قليل ان المساعدات
الاوروبيه من المنتظر ان تصل قريبا جدا
السلطات تركيا تعول كثيرا على المساعدات
من خارج تركيا وايضا على وصول فرق الانقاذ
من الولايات التركيه الكبرى الى المناطق
المنكوبه لتسريع عمليات الانقاذ والوصول
الى العالقين تحت الانقاض في محاوله نوعا
ما لتقليل الخسائر البشريه التي كما ذكرت
من المتوقع ان ترتفع اليوم تركيا تعيش
اكبر كارثه منذ قرن تقريبا منذ عام
1939 وفق ما اكد الرئيس التركي صباح هذا
اليوم
زيدان يعني الفرق الانقاذ التي تصل لتساعد
على انتشال الضحايا ويعني المنكوبين هناك
وايضا المساعدات الانسانيه على اي مطر تصل
وكيف يتم نقل الى الاماكن المنكوبه خصوصا
انه تم اقفال عدد من المطارات هناك
نعم الانباء التي وصلتنا
ان الى مطاري اضنه وغازي عنتاب مطار ابونا
توقف لفتره ومن ثم تم اعاده تشغيل المقال
لاستقبال المساعدات وفرق الانقاذ وايضا
تقريبا ايضا الحديث عن مطار غازي عنتاب
نفس اصوات وتوقف لفتره قصيره مثل استئناف
العمل سهله الرحلات حتى ان الرحلات
المدنيه رحلات الطيران المدني التي توقفت
اليوم بدات شركات الطيران بطرح بعض
التذاكر للرحلات يوم غد الثلاثاء الى بعض
المناطق في جنوب تركيا وهناك اطفال كبير
على شراء التذاكر الى هناك
الكثير من الاتراك يرغبون بالوصول الى
اقاربهم في تلك المناطق بالعموم نحن نتحدث
عن
نتحدث عن عمليات انقاذ ما زالت مستمره حتى
هذه اللحظه وكما ذكرنا ان 17 طائره ستصل
تباعا الى مطاري اضنه وغازي عنتاب المشكله
الان التي تعترض فرق الانقاذ والسلطات
التركيه هي الطرق التي انهارت في بعض
المناطق ما بين الولايات على سبيل المثال
الطريق بين ولايه غازي عنتاب قد تدمر قد
انهار جزء منهم بفعل الزلزال وزاره الدفاع
التركيه التي ارسلت سفن لاجلاء الراغبين
او الراغبين بالخروج من هاتايا عبر ميناء
اسكندرون بالتالي المواطنين الموجودين في
غازي عنتاب لن يستطيعوا الانتقال الى هناك
بسبب انقطاع الطرق ايضا هناك عامل اخر وهو
سوء الاحوال الجويه وموجه البرد والثلوج
التي تغطي المنطقه ايضا تعيق العمل هذا ما
اكده قبل قليل نائب الرئيس التركي وعندما
تحدث صعوبه الوصول ومحاوله ايجاد طرق
بديله الطرق البديله لن تكون بنفس الجوده
للطرق الرئيسيه التي انهارت اجزاء منها
وهذا يعني ان وصول فرق الانقاذ ربما
سيتاخر الى بعض المناطق اللافت
الصور المبجعه هنا نتحدث عنها الصور التي
ظهرت قبل حوالي ساعتين من كهرمان مرعش هذه
الولايه التي ضربها
زلزلان قويان الاول كانت بشدته 7.7 على
مقياس ريختر والثاني
7.6 على مقياس ريختر بين الزلزلين تقريبا
حوالي تسع ساعات كانت يعني الصور التي
رايناها حي كامل قد دمر بالكامل عشرات
المنازل قد
سويت في الارض ما عدا مبنى كان مبنى ضخم
حتى هذا المبنى كان قائلا للسقوط وفرق
الانقاذ تحاول للوصول الى الى العالقين
تحت الانقاض وكانت يعني هذا المشهد حقيقه
كان يلخص كل المعاناه عشرات المنازل يعني
وفرق الانقاذ تقف تحاول بذل كل الامكانيات
للوصول الى العالقين هذا المشهد حقيقه كان
يلخص كل ما تشهده تركيا اليوم من معاناه
في الوصول الى العالقين تحت الانقاذ تحت
الانقاض ومحاوله قدر الامكان انقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه والوصول الى الناجين والاحياء
تحت هذا تحت اقوام واطنان من الركام
والكتل الخرسانيه الضخمه وهذا يتطلب جهود
اضافيه واعداد اضافيه وايضا اليات اضافيه
في منطقه كهرمان مرعشيه منطقه جبليه واعره
نوعا ما اذا كان الطريق الرئيسي متضرر هذا
يعني اللجوء الى طرق بديله ستكون اكثر
واوراق وهذا ايضا سيزيد المهمه او المهمه
صعوبه على فرق الالقاد
بالحديث زيدان عن المساعدات اليابان ايضا
اعلنت ارسال فرق انقاذ الى تركيا لتقديم
المساعدات الطارئه عقب هذا الزلزال على كل
حال زيدان سنبقى نتابع معك الصوره من هناك
كيف يتم يعني اغاثه المنكوبين والمجروحين
وكل الجرحى طبعا وكل من اصبحوا اليوم بدون
ماوى في تركيا بعد هذه الكارثه التي حلت
بالمناطق التركيه شكرا لك زيدان زنك
لمراسل العربيه حدثنا من اسطنبول
افادت وكاله الانباء السعوديه بان ولي
العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن سلمان قدم
التعازي هاتفيا للرئيس التركي اردوغان في
ضحايا الزلزال واكد الامير محمد بن سلمان
وقوف السعوديه ومساندتها لتركيا لتجاوز
هذه الكارثه الطبيعيه بدوره اعرب اردوغان
عن تقديره لوقوف السعوديه الى جانب تركيا
في هذا الظرف الصعب
بدورها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
انشاء مشفى ميداني في قاعده حميمي الروسيه
في سوريا لتقديم المساعده لضحايا الزلزال
وجاء في بيان الوزاره بانه تم انشاء
مجموعه متنقله من المسعفين العسكريين
الروس في قاعده تحميميم الجويه وهي في
حاله تاهب دائم لتقديم المساعده باكثر من
300 عسكري و60 وحده من المعدات العسكريه
تشارك في اعمال المساعده اضافه الى ان
القوات الروسيه تنشئ سته مراكز لتوزيع
المساعدات الانسانيه في المدن السوريه
تنضم الينا من موسكو كاتيا طعم مراسلات
العربيه كاتيا يعني منذ الصباح كان قد
اعلن يعني باتصال طبعا بين الرئيسين
السوري والروسي عن تقديم المساعده وعن
الوقوف الى جانب سوريا بهذه المصاب ماذا
عن المساعدات لتركيا وكيف تترجم المساعدات
في سوريا
مرحبا ليال بالفعل سيتم تجهيز او تم تخصيص
اربع طائرات تابعه للطوارئ الروسيه سيتم
تجهيزها وبتكون طبعا محمله برجال الانقاذ
لارسالها الى المناطق المنكوبه طبعا اول
طائره توجهت الان تحمل نائب وزير الطوارئ
الكساندر شوبريان سيتوجه الى تركيا عبر
هذه الطائره المحمله بفرق الانقاذ هي
طائره محمله بطاقه ام كامل فيما يخص
عمليات الانقاذ في تركيا باضافه الى
طائرتين
اخرتين سيتم توجيهها الى تركيا وطائره
واحده ستوجه الى سوريا هذه الطائرات التي
ستحمل او تم تجهيز فريق انقاذ مؤلف 100
متخصص في مجال الدمار الكارثي وسبعه اطقم
من الاطباء
ومن الكلاب كلاب البحث بالاضافه طبعا 40
متخصص من قسم المساعدات التي ستقدم
مساعدات على الارض هناك في منطقه الدمار
او في منطقه الكوارث التي وقعت في تركيا
وفي سوريا هذا بالاضافه الى ان وزير
الدفاع
هل وزير الطوارئ الروسي سيتوجه الى تركيا
يعني للوقوف الى جانب
الشعب التركي والحكومه التركيه هناك ام
سيرسلون فرق لمساعده في الالقاب
نائب وزير الطوارئ سيتوجه او توجه توجه
على بطن طائره يتوجهت الى تركيا
بالاضافه الى طاقم كامل من فريق الانقاذ
من جميع المساعدات اللازمه لعمليات
الانقاذ هناك على الارض توجهت الان الى
تركيا بالاضافه الى ذلك سيكون هناك
طائرتين اخرتين ستنت وجهها الى تركيا
وطائره واحده ستتوجه الى سوريا من اجل
عمليات الانقلاب
اي تمثيل على مستوى نائب وزير الطوارئ ام
انها فقط مساعدات وفرق انقاذ
حقيقه حتى الان هي فقط فرق انقاذ مؤلفه من
رجال انقاذ ومن فرق طبيه بالاضافه لذلك
وزير الدفاع
[موسيقى]
كان قد اوعى اصدقائي بمجموعات الفرق
العسكريه المتواجده الان في سوريا
بتجهيز او بتجهيز 10 فرقعه للجيش الروسي
التي هي ايضا ستقوم بتقديم مساعدات هناك
سواء كانت باداء مهام ازاله الانقاذ هناك
او البحث عن الضحايا او تقديم مساعدات
طبيه له في هذه المناطق التي تعرضت لدمار
دمار كبير بالاضافه لذلك
سيتم او سيتم نشر عناصر المراكز المركز
الروسي بالمصالحه بين الاطراف المتحاربه
في في حلب وحماه والذي قيم لتقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه ايضا للضحايا كما
تحدثت ايضا الطوارئ ان هناك مستشفى متنقل
سيتم ايضا تسليمه مناطق المناطق التي وقعت
فيها
الكوارثيه لن تقتصر على مناطق سيطره
النظام هل هذا ما تقولينه الان
حقيقه كما ذكرت لك اولا سيتعمل على جهتين
الطائره الاولى ستتوجه الى منطقه الكوارث
في سوريا لم يتم طبعا تحديد المناطق التي
تتوجه اليها ولكن على الارض كما تعلمين
هناك ايضا قوات العسكريه المتواجده التي
يعاد لها بان تقوم تقديم مساعدات للضحايا
هناك وبالتالي هي متواجده في المناطق التي
ذكرتها لك في وقت سابق هي كانت في
اللاذقيه وحماه ومناطق جبله
بالاضافه الى مناطق اخرى لم يتم الكشف اذا
كانت هي فقط ستكون تابعه للسلطات الروسيه
او السلطات الاخرى التي لا تعود او ليست
تعبئه للسلطات الرسميه في دمشق كاتيا يعني
باطار هذه المساعدات اين ستحط الطائرات
الروسيه كلها ستكون في مطار حميم ام ان
بعضها يعني بعض الفرق الانقاص ستدخل عبر
الحدود التركيه السوريه
طائره واحده فقط ليال ستتوجه الى سوريا
وثلاث طائرات ستتوجه الى تركيا
لم يتم الحديث بعد
عن فيه الطائرات الروسيه سواء كانت في
تركيا او في سوريا لربما ستتحول او ستتوجه
مباشره الى الشمال السوري الى حلب الى
منطقه الكارثه هناك التي وقعت او المنطقه
الاكبر في الشمال السوري او سيتم توجيها
الى حنيمهم حتى الان لم يتم الكشف عن هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل الكامله
اسمحي لي ان اشير الى هذه العواجل عن وكيل
امين عام الامم المتحده يقول بان فرق
الطوارئ مستعده لدعم جهود الاغاثه في
تركيا وسوريا وزير الدفاع التركيه يقول
بان القوات الخاصه تشارك في اغاثه ضحايا
الزلزال وايضا عن وزير الدفاع التركيه
السفن الحربيه تشارك في اجراء متضرري
زلزال من انطاكيا الى مرسين اذا حاله
طوارئ كبرى يعني نشهدها على مستوى الاراضي
التركيه حيث تشارك كل الفرق الرسميه وال
والدوليه بعمليه الاغاثه طبعا في سوريا
كاتيا الوضع مختلف قليلا بسبب الانقسام
الحاصل هناك يعني الى اي مدى ستكون
المساعدات التركيه
فاعله على الارض كيف سيتم توزيع بالتنسيق
مع قوات النظام ام ايضا ستتعاون مع منظمات
انسانيه وحقوقيه
حقيقه ليال كما ذكرت لك القوات التي
بالاساس هي كانت على الارض قوات الروسيه
الموجوده في منطقه الان سيتم بتفعيلها من
اجل تقديم مساعدات على الارض سيتم طبعا
ستعمل على توزيع المساعدات ولكن بالدرجه
الاولى هي ستقوم برفع الانقاض هناك طبعا
دمار شامل كنا شاهدناه في مدينه حلب هي
التي تقع تحت السيطره السلطات السوريه
وبالتالي التنسيق فيما اذا كان هناك سيكون
توزيع ايضا مساعدات او المساعده في
رفع الالقاب في المناطق الاخرى حتى الان
لا يوجد مخطط كامل او لم يتم الكشف عنه عن
هذه الاليه التي سيتم العمل بها على
الاراضي السوريه ليال نعم شكرا لك كاتيا
طعم مراسله العربيه حدثنا من موسكو وشكرا
لكل الزملاء الذين وفونا بهذه الرسائل من
معظم الدول الاوروبيه ومن تركيا